[Music]
biologic medicines are proteins produced
inside living cells which are many
factories generating the genetically
engineered protein treatments it's a
different approach from traditional
drugs which are manufactured using
chemical synthesis biologics offer hope
where other therapies have failed to
mass-produce these biologic medicines
scientists use the molecular machinery
inside living cells the process starts
with the insertion of genetic material
into Chinese hamster ovarian cells
they're known as CH o cells they keep
them frozen in liquid nitrogen
until the next step in the seed lab a
technician Falls the cells and warm
water
he transfers them to a glass flask that
contains growth medium the growth media
is comprised of hundreds of nutrients
including vitamins and minerals it's a
recipe to help the cells multiply a
[Music]
worker transfers the flask that contains
the cells to the production side of the
plant the team injects the mixture into
a five gallon capacity bioreactor inside
a propeller agitates the mixture to
stimulate growth over a three-week
period the number of cells increases
exponentially each new cell is
programmed to produce the target
biologic protein next a technician
measures salts and other dry ingredients
he's preparing a recipe for purifying
the protein liquid once it's been
separated from the cells he labels the
bag and records the information
separately as required by government
regulations he adds the ingredients to
purified water in a mixing tank an
automated system keeps tabs on the
condition of the purification solution
[Music]
after separating cellular material from
the protein mixture the team pumps it
through steel and glass columns here the
purification solution works with resin
beads to separate the protein from the
impurities
finally this technician takes a sample
and conducts a test to ensure the
medicine is sterile grown and living
cells these biologic medicines are now
on their way to potentially making a
difference in people's lives
[Music]